كلما مرت البلدان بمشاكل اقتصاديه كبرى
واوضاعا اجتماعيه صعبه زادت عمليات
الاحتيال وهنا استغلت شركه هوتش بول الامر
مستعينه بنموذج يدعى سلسله المصطلح
ظهر في كاليفورنيا عام 1920 ويقوم على
استغلال بريق الثراء السريع على العقول من
اجل استدراج الاشخاص للوقوع في الفخ
والمنفذ كان الايطاليه
لكن في الولايات المتحده تحديدا
كاليفورنيا نظام هرمي او تسويق شبكي
والفكره بسيطه يدعوا اموالهم وكسبوا ارباح
كبيره خلال فتره محدده دون التعرض لاي
مخاطر استثماريه
اسس شركه تقوم على تبادل الطوابع البريديه
من مختلف الدول واستبدالها في امريكا
لتحقيق هامش الربح طور بونزي مخططه
واستدرج مستثمرين وشجعهم على ايداع
اموالهم ليحقق ارباحا وصلت الى
250 الف دولار يوميا قبل اعتقاله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كيف تعمل اذا ناء فكره بونزي وكيف يربح
البعض اموالا في البدايه الامر لا يتم من
خلال ارباح مشاريع استثماريه بل عبر الدفع
فوائد للمستثمرين الاقدم من اموال
المدخرين الجدد هذا يساهم في بناء الثقه
بالطبع التي تكون اول خطواتها هي الوثائق
حيث يتم اهام المدخرين بوسائق تكاد تكون
حقيقيه في حاله هوتش بول في مصر مثلا
التطبيق له رخصه رخصه سجل تجاري مصري لكن
مسؤولا مسؤولا بوزاره التموين والتجاره
الداخليه اكد ان هذه الاوراق ليست ترخيصا
بل مجرد قيد لعلامه تجاريه ولا تخول
لحاملها الترخيص باي نشاط الا بعد اتمام
اوراق ترخيصه من جميع الجهات المعنيه
عموما تستمر هذه الحلقه على هذا النحو
اموال مودعه تذهب للمودعين الجدد وبعدها
يتمكن من تحقيق الارباح بقيمه معينه يقوم
بسحبها ثم يختفي والكثيرون على مدار سنوات
استفادوا من فكره المحتال الايطالي فانسي
[موسيقى]